In Danielle's house, ever since she was a girl, when holiday dinners come, they serve a meal that will probably look familiar to you. Picture main course, big platter, drum sticks, white breast meat, golden brown skin, stuffing, and gravy, and cranberry relish on the side. And in Danielle's family they have a name for this meal that she told me on the phone recently. The name for this meal is--
在丹妮尔家里，从小时候起，每当节日晚餐时，他们都会上一道你可能很熟悉的菜。想象一下主菜：一大盘，鸡腿、白嫩的鸡胸肉、金黄的酥皮、填料、肉汁，旁边还有蔓越莓酱。在丹妮尔的家族里，他们给这道菜起了一个名字，她最近在电话里告诉了我。这个名字是——
Fish.
鱼。
Got that?
明白了吗？
Fish.
鱼。
Well, from WBEZ Chicago and Public Radio International, it's This American Life. A special program today on the wonders of fish.
各位好，来自芝加哥WBEZ电台和国际公共广播电台，这里是《这个美国生活》。今天是一个关于鱼之奇迹的特别节目。
Actually, we can say the word here, and the word is poultry. And as you know, each week on our program we choose some theme, invite a variety of writers and performers to tackle that theme. And this week, as we stand now in that magical five weeks of the year, that magical five weeks between the turkey served at Thanksgiving and the turkey served at Christmas, a period when Americans consume nearly a fourth of all the turkey consumed in this country every year. And every year during this important time, This American Life brings you yet another program about poultry. That's right-- stories about turkeys, chickens, ducks, fowl of all kind, and their mysterious hold over us.
事实上，我们可以在这里说出那个词，那个词是家禽。如你所知，我们节目的每周都会选择一个主题，邀请不同的作家和表演者来探讨这个主题。而本周，当我们正处于一年中那神奇的五周时——感恩节烤火鸡到圣诞节烤火鸡之间那神奇的五周，这期间美国人消费了全国每年近四分之一的火鸡。每年在这个重要时刻，《这个美国生活》都会为您带来一期关于家禽的节目。没错，就是关于火鸡、鸡、鸭、各种禽类以及它们对我们产生的神秘吸引力的故事。
I'm Ira Glass. Coming up this hour, Act One: Duki. The story of a typical American family and imaginary poultry. Act Two: what poultry-positive program would be complete without--
我是艾拉·格拉斯。本小时即将播出，第一幕：杜基。一个典型美国家庭与虚构家禽的故事。第二幕：如果没有这个，什么样的家禽主题节目才算完整呢——
Chickenman!
鸡侠！
He's everywhere, he's everywhere!
他无处不在，他无处不在！
Yes, indeed. In the late 1960s, the winged warrior struck terror in the hearts of evildoers on radios all across this great nation. Today, my friends, he flies again. Act Three: Chicken Diva. In that act, an opera about Chicken Little sung in Italian, and-- no kidding-- able to make a grown man cry. Act Four: Trying To Respect The Chicken. The story of one woman's quest to try to give chickens the honor and the dignity that they are rarely accorded, even though the chickens resist her efforts.
没错，确实如此。在20世纪60年代末，这位长翅膀的勇士在全国各地的广播电台里令恶徒们闻风丧胆。今天，我的朋友们，他再次起飞。第三幕：鸡影后。在那一幕中，有一部用意大利语演唱的关于“鸡丁”的歌剧，而且——说真的——它能让一个大男人流泪。第四幕：试图尊重鸡。故事讲述了一位女性试图赋予鸡它们很少享有的荣誉和尊严，尽管鸡群抵制她的努力。
Stay with us.
请继续收听。
Act One: Duki. So in Danielle's family, the power of poultry is so great in their lives that when they serve chicken or turkey, they call it--
第一幕：杜基。在丹妮尔的家族里，家禽在他们的生活中有着巨大的影响力，以至于当他们上鸡肉或火鸡时，他们称之为——
Fish.
鱼。
That's right. And they call it this for a reason. And the reason has to do with a stuffed hand puppet called Duki.
没错。他们这样称呼是有原因的。这个原因与一个名叫杜基的毛绒手偶有关。
Now, Danielle, is a woman over 30 years old. Her sister Ashley is two years younger. Duki has been in the family since they were children.
丹妮尔今年30多岁了。她的妹妹阿什利比她小两岁。杜基在他们还是孩子的时候就已经在家里了。
Well, he was a Christmas present when Ashley was about 8 and I was about 10. And when he first arrived, he was really fluffy. And he was this beautiful, fluffy, white duck. He had a cape on and black kind of villain slash hero goggles. He lost the outfit pretty quickly and he went naked. And then he became Ashley's vehicle for torturing me.
嗯，它是阿什利大约8岁、我10岁那年的圣诞礼物。刚到家时，它非常蓬松。那是一只漂亮、毛茸茸的白鸭子。它披着斗篷，戴着黑色的反派兼英雄护目镜。它很快就弄丢了那身行头，光秃秃的了。后来它成了阿什利折磨我的工具。
It's not unusual for older siblings to dominate younger ones. And as children, Danielle dominated Ashley. Ashley looked up to Danielle, fought to get her attention and her approval, and Danielle always, always got her way. Except when Duki was around.
年长的兄弟姐妹支配年幼的往往很常见。小时候，丹妮尔总是压制阿什利。阿什利仰慕丹妮尔，争取她的关注和认可，而丹妮尔总是随心所欲。除了杜基在场的时候。
Basically, Ashley would channel-- I mean, the word's kind of an anachronism in this context-- but she would channel Duki. She would become Duki's voice. She would speak as Duki. And Duki was sarcastic. Duki was selfish and bossy. Duki would insult Danielle. Duki would tease Danielle. Duki would give her painful nose squeaks.
基本上，阿什利会附身——我是说，在这种语境下这个词有点时代错误——但她会通过杜基说话。她会成为杜基的代言人。杜基非常刻薄。杜基自私又霸道。杜基会侮辱丹妮尔，嘲弄丹妮尔。杜基还会捏她的鼻子发出吱吱声。
Whenever Ashley brought Duki into the equation, he was completely the dominant force. I was just putty in Duki's hands.
每当阿什利把杜基带入这种状态，它就成了绝对的主导力量。我在杜基手中就像橡皮泥一样任人摆布。
Let me ask you to compare his personality with Ashley's personality.
让我请你比较一下它和阿什利的性格。
Ashley is very kind of considerate, and-- she's very considerate and kind and thoughtful. And very, very sensitive to other people. Very, very concerned about if other people are happy and if someone or someone else doesn't feel good. And Duki has this total, like, you know, what's for lunch attitude. Like what's in it for me, in your face, totally out for himself. Simultaneously a braggart and a total wimp.
阿什利非常体贴，而且——她非常有同情心、善良且细心。非常非常在意别人的感受，关心别人是否快乐，或者别人是否不舒服。而杜基完全是一种“午餐吃什么”的态度。就好像“我能从中得到什么”，很直白，完全为自己着想。既是一个吹牛大王，又是个彻头彻尾的懦夫。
He's boastful and vain.
它既自大又虚荣。
He's just this indomitable-- yeah-- indomitable spirit.
它就是那种不屈不挠的——是的——不屈不挠的精神。
All right. I've been at Daniels apartment sometimes, and I've witnessed the following scene-- picture, please. Danielle has not spoken with her sister in weeks. She picks up the phone, calls Ashley in Michigan. Ashley answers. Danielle asks immediately, "can you put Duki on?"
好了。我有时在丹妮尔的公寓里，目睹过以下场景——请想象一下。丹妮尔已经几周没和她妹妹说话了。她拿起电话，打给密歇根州的阿什利。阿什利接了电话。丹妮尔立刻问：“能让杜基接电话吗？”
And then Ashley essentially becomes Duki, puts Duki on the phone. Danielle talks to Duki for 15, 20 minutes. And then they both hang up. That's the whole conversation. And they both feel satisfied. These are adult-- Danielle is an editor at a big New York magazine.
然后阿什利基本上就变成了杜基，让杜基接电话。丹妮尔和杜基聊了15、20分钟。然后他们都挂了电话。这就是整个对话。他们都感到满足。这些都是成年人——丹妮尔是纽约一家大型杂志社的编辑。
I adore Duki. I really love Duki. And sometimes I think if he disappeared, it would really feel like someone died. I mean, I look at him and he looks really kind of old and ratty, and it really makes me sad. I feel like-- it sounds crazy. It really makes me sad to think about a world without Duki. And that it would be a big empty hole the world.
我爱杜基。我真的很爱杜基。有时我觉得如果它消失了，真的会感觉像死了亲人一样。我是说，看着它，它看起来真的很旧、很破烂，这让我很难过。我觉得——这听起来很疯狂。一想到没有杜基的世界，我就真的很伤心。那会是世界上一个巨大的空洞。
He kind of takes up as much room in my heart as a lot of people individually. And if something happened to him, you know, if he were lost at an airport or run over by a car, it would really be heartbreaking.
它在我心中的位置，和许多人作为个体在我心中的位置一样重。如果它发生了什么意外，比如在机场丢了或者被车轧了，真的会让人心碎。
So I hope it's becoming clear why, if you eat dinner in the home of Danielle's family, if they're serving some kind of poultry-- you know, chicken or turkey-- if you were to ask anybody in the family, "what's for dinner," they'll tell you--
所以我想现在很清楚了，为什么如果你在丹妮尔家里吃晚饭，如果他们上的是禽肉——比如鸡肉或火鸡——如果你问家里任何人“晚饭吃什么”，他们会告诉你——
Fish.
鱼。
Right. And the rationale for that is what?
没错。那么理由是什么呢？
It freaks Duki out.
那会把杜基吓坏的。
It freaks him out, though-- you don't like him to know that perhaps some birds are, in fact, eaten?
这会吓坏它，不过——你不希望它知道事实上有些鸟类确实是被吃掉的？
I think he knows. I think he's in denial about it. He's in denial about most things. He's in denial about the fact that he's totally weak and tiny and dirty. He thinks he's really good looking and strong. And that he's really smart and has a lot of friends.
我想它是知道的。我想它对此在进行自我否认。它对大多数事情都在否认。它否认自己其实很虚弱、渺小又肮脏的事实。它认为自己长得很帅、很强壮，而且它很聪明，有很多朋友。
He's in denial about the fact that he's actually stuffed, which he is. Sometimes I tell him, and I say, "Duki, give me a break-- you're just stuffed." And he's like, "no way."
它否认自己其实是个填充玩具的事实，而它确实是。有时我告诉它，我说：“杜基，饶了我吧，你只是个填充玩具。”它就说：“才不是呢。”
Now, I thought I would try to book Duki to come on the radio for this program. So I contacted Danielle's sister Ashley and asked her, you know, "could Duki come on the air?" I received an answer back not by phone, but by electronic mail that for Duki to appear, I'd have to first go through someone named Yona Lu, who I could reach through Danielle and Ashley's mother. And when I talked to Danielle, I asked her about this.
现在，我想尝试预约杜基来参加这个节目的广播。所以我联系了丹妮尔的妹妹阿什利，问她：“杜基能上节目吗？”我收到的回复不是通过电话，而是通过电子邮件。她说如果杜基要上节目，我必须先通过一个叫约娜·卢的人，我可以联系丹妮尔和阿什利的妈妈。当我和丹妮尔谈话时，我问了这件事。
I've been informed that the only way that I can reach him is by calling your mom and speaking to Yona Lu? Do I have that name right?
我被告知联系它的唯一方法是打给你妈妈，和约娜·卢交谈？那个名字我没记错吧？
Yona Lu, yeah.
约娜·卢，是的。
Yona Lu.
约娜·卢。
I think that's-- she's acting as his agent.
我想那是——她在担任它的经纪人。
Yona Lu is?
约娜·卢是吗？
She's a hedgehog.
她是一只刺猬。
Anything special that I should say to Yona Lu to make this happen?
有什么特别的话是我该对约娜·卢说的，好让这件事促成吗？
I mean, I don't know. She's a pretty-- she drives a pretty hard bargain.
我是说，我不知道。她挺……她很难讨价还价的。
[PHONE RINGING]
[电话铃声]
Hello?
喂？
Hey, Mrs. Mattoon?
嘿，马通太太？
Yes.
是。
It's Ira Glass.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。
Hi, Ira Glass.
你好，艾拉·格拉斯。
Mrs. Mattoon, here's why I called you. I want to do a little story on the radio about Duki.
马通太太，我打电话是这样，我想在广播里做一段关于杜基的小故事。
Duki.
杜基。
And I contacted your daughter Ashley, and she said that for me to book Duki onto my radio show, I was going to first need to contact Yona Lu.
我联系了你女儿阿什利，她说如果要预约杜基上我的广播节目，我需要先联系约娜·卢。
Yona Lu. [LAUGHING]
约娜·卢。[笑]
Yeah, you would need to do that.
是的，你需要这样做。
And that I needed to do that through you.
并且我需要通过你来做这件事。
Yeah.
是的。
Who is Yona Lu.
约娜·卢是谁？
Yona Lu is-- she's a hedgehog. She's basically taken charge of Duki's financial affairs. And I presume this is something to do with money?
约娜·卢是——她是一只刺猬。她基本上接管了杜基的财务事务。我想这和钱有关？
Well, I don't know, actually. I mean, we--
嗯，事实上我也不知道。我是说，我们——
That's probably why she said to contact Yona Lu.
那可能就是她让你联系约娜·卢的原因。
Well, so what do I do now? I'm calling-- I was told to contact you if I wanted to get in touch with Yona Lu in order to book Duki. What do I do next?
嗯，那我该怎么办？我打电话——我被告知如果想联系约娜·卢来预约杜基，就要联系你。接下来我该做什么？
Book Duki, OK. You're gonna' book Duki?
预约杜基，好。你要预约杜基？
That's the whole idea. I want to book Duki for the show for an interview.
就是这个想法。我想预约杜基来节目接受采访。
Well, I'll just talk to Yona Lu about it. She says OK, it's OK.
嗯，我会和约娜·卢谈谈。她说可以，那就没问题。
Would Yona Lu want to discuss terms or something?
约娜·卢会想讨论条件之类的吗？
She doesn't talk.
她不说话。
So what's going to happen? All right. Should I call you back?
那会发生什么呢？好了。我该回电话给你吗？
You could call me back, or I'll just go in and check.
你可以打回来，或者我会进去看看。
You'll just go in and check?
你会进去看看？
Yeah.
是的。
Should I wait?
我该等吗？
Yeah.
是的。
All right, I'll wait.
好的，我等。
Ira?
艾拉？
Yeah.
在。
This is just radio?
这只是广播节目？
Yeah.
是的。
Not TV?
不是电视？
It's just radio.
只是广播。
And nobody is going to get to be on TV?
没人会出现在电视上吧？
[IRA LAUGHING]
[艾拉笑]
No, no one's going to be on TV. No, it's strictly radio.
不，没人会上电视。不，纯粹是广播。
OK. Yona Lu doesn't care what happens then.
好的，那约娜·卢不在乎会发生什么了。
What if it were TV?
如果是电视节目会怎样？
I think she'd want to be on, too. [IRA LAUGHING] Even though she doesn't-- I mean, radio doesn't do much for her because she doesn't talk.
我想她也会想上的。[艾拉笑] 尽管她不——我是说，广播对她没太大用处，因为她不说话。
All right. As you might imagine, not everybody in the family takes all this so lightly. Danielle's father was never too keen on this.
好了。正如你可能想象的那样，并不是家里每个人都这么轻松地看待这一切。丹妮尔的父亲从不怎么喜欢这个。
He was quite actually bothered by the whole-- he thought we maybe had a problem in the family.
他其实很被整个事情困扰——他认为我们家里可能有问题。
Really?
真的吗？
Mm-hm. [AFFIRMATIVE] I mean, for a while there, we had two daughters that only communicated through a duck.
嗯。[肯定] 我是说，有一段时间，我们家有两个女儿只能通过一只鸭子交流。
Yeah. That period that you're describing, when do you mean?
是的。你描述的那个时期，是指什么时候？
I would say they maybe were 10 and 12 or 9 and 11.
我想她们可能10岁和12岁，或者9岁和11岁的时候。
And they would only communicate through the duck?
她们只会通过鸭子交流？
Well, Danielle didn't pay a whole lot of attention to Ashley, but she paid quite a lot of attention to the duck. So if Ashley wanted to get Danielle's attention, all she had to do was rev up the duck.
嗯，丹妮尔不怎么关注阿什利，但她对那只鸭子很关注。所以如果阿什利想引起丹妮尔的注意，她只需要发动那只鸭子。
And how long did this last?
这持续了多久？
I can't remember. She'd also make Danielle laugh that way. Danielle thought Duki was very funny, but I can't remember her thinking Ashley was funny.
我不记得了。她也会用那种方式逗丹妮尔笑。丹妮尔认为杜基很有趣，但我记不起她觉得阿什利很有趣。
In terms of the relationship between my sister and me, I don't know why-- I mean, this is probably completely, really sick-- but I have so much genuine affection and love for Duki that it's very easy, and it's very easy to demonstrate those feelings, in a way that it's not as easy to kind of demonstrate those feelings toward my sister. Just because we never got in the habit of it.
关于我和妹妹的关系，我不知道为什么——我是说，这可能真的很病态——但我对杜基有非常纯粹的喜爱和爱，以至于很容易表达这些感受，而对我妹妹表达这些感受却没那么容易。只是因为我们从来没养成那样的习惯。
What percentage of your relationship with your sister is based on your relationship with Duki?
你和你妹妹的关系中，有多少比例是基于你和杜基的关系？
Well, the really fun part of it is based on my relationship with Duki. But I think as we've gotten older and older, we've gotten more and more self-conscious about the Duki factor in our relationship. But I think kind of a big chunk. I mean, it definitely kind of gives me this vision into her brain that I wouldn't have otherwise.
嗯，非常有趣的部分是基于我和杜基的关系。但我认为随着我们越来越大，我们在关系中对“杜基因素”感到越来越不自在。但我认为占了很大一部分。我是说，它绝对让我对她的思维有了一个视角，否则我是不会有的。
Well, I did finally snag an interview with Duki by calling Ashley.
好吧，我最终通过给阿什利打电话，争取到了对杜基的采访。
Is Duki still up for this?
杜基还愿意接受采访吗？
Yeah. He just got back from a party, though.
可以。不过它刚从派对回来。
He just got back from a party?
它刚从派对回来？
Yeah. He was at a happy hour thing with a lot of college students. He's not in college, but he's in a band, so a lot of his friends go to this happy hour on Friday nights.
是的。它和一个大学生去参加了一个快乐时光活动。它没上大学，但它在一个乐队里，所以它的很多朋友周五晚上会去参加这个快乐时光。
All right. Well, could you get him?
好了。嗯，能让它接电话吗？
Uh, sure. He's upstairs-- just a sec.
嗯，当然。它在楼上——等一下。
OK.
好的。
Here he is.
它来了。
Hey, Duki?
嘿，杜基？
Yeah? Hey, Ira, how ya' doin'?
什么？嘿，艾拉，你好吗？
I'm just fine.
我很好。
Long time no see.
好久不见。
Long time no see back at you. And welcome to our little radio program.
好久不见。欢迎来到我们的小广播节目。
So what's going on here? You've got a whole bunch of celebrities on tonight?
今天晚上这儿有什么大人物吗？
Well, we actually have a number of different people.
嗯，我们确实有很多不同的人。
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE] like Tom Cruise?
[听不清] 像汤姆·克鲁斯那样？
They're just like Tom Cruise.
他们就像汤姆·克鲁斯一样。
OK.
好吧。
Now, Duki, I was talking to Danielle for our radio program and had her come on and talk about you a little bit. And one of the things that she said was that when she was younger, in order to discipline her if she was doing something that you didn't like, you could pretty much control her with something called nose squeaks.
现在，杜基，我为了节目和丹妮尔谈过了，让她来讲讲你。她说当你年轻的时候，如果她做了你不喜欢的事，你为了管教她，几乎可以用所谓的“鼻子吱吱声”来控制她。
Yeah. Because she has this kind of-- it's a prominent nose, you know what I mean? Kind of sticks out and you just want to squeak it. You know, like, over Thanksgiving we were watching The Muppet Show. And Miss Piggy was on, and she reminded me a lot of Niellie.
是的。因为它有那种——它的鼻子很突出，你知道吗？有点凸出来，你就是想捏它吱吱叫。你知道，感恩节时我们在看《木偶秀》。猪小姐也在，她让我想起了很多尼利（丹妮尔）。
Of Danielle?
丹妮尔？
Mm-hm. [AFFIRMATIVE] Yeah. And Kermit told Miss Piggy, "move the pork." And so I was telling Niellie to move the pork all week.
嗯。[肯定] 是的。科米蛙告诉猪小姐：“把猪肉挪开。”所以整个星期我都在叫尼利挪开猪肉。
And would she move?
她挪开了吗？
Yes, she would. She would.
是的，她挪了。
Now, if Ashley would tell her, if Ashley would sit down on the couch and say to Danielle, "move the pork," what would the effect of that be?
现在，如果阿什利告诉她，如果阿什利坐在沙发上对丹妮尔说“把猪肉挪开”，会有什么效果？
Kind of-- you know Niellie. You know how she looks at you when she doesn't approve of something you say or do. She gets this kind of ice-cold stare and she gives you this sidelong glance that makes you kind of feel like you're about the size of a pea.
有点——你知道尼利。你知道当她不赞同你说的话或做的事时，她怎么看你。她会露出那种冰冷的眼神，斜视你，让你感觉自己只有豌豆那么大。
Yeah.
是的。
That's what she does.
她就是那样。
Is there anything about the life of a duck that perhaps you could tell our radio audience that we might not know? I'm sure that you know much more about it than we do.
关于鸭子的生活，有什么你能告诉我们的广播听众，而我们可能不知道的吗？我相信你知道的比我们多得多。
No, not really. I'm kind of an unusual duck. I'm not really in touch with the whole duck scene.
不，没那么特别。我是个不寻常的鸭子。我不太关注整个鸭子界。
You're not in touch with the whole scene, yeah.
你不关注整个鸭子界，是吗？
When I had time, I used to migrate once in a while because I have some friends who are ducks. And I try to keep in touch with them, but lately I just started spending more time with people and doing my own thing. And I just don't have time to do those kind of duck things anymore. I just wanted more in my life than that.
以前有时间的时候，我偶尔会迁徙，因为我有些鸭子朋友。我试图和他们保持联系，但最近我开始花更多时间陪伴人类，做我自己的事情。我只是没时间再去做那些鸭子的事了。我的人生想要更多东西。
Duki, a stuffed hand puppet, now lives in New York City.
杜基，一个毛绒手偶，现在住在纽约市。
Well, the story of a 27 year old graduate student who talks like a duck naturally brings us to the story of Chickenman.
嗯，一个像鸭子一样说话的27岁研究生的故事，自然让我们想到了鸡侠的故事。
Chickenman first soared the radio airwaves from 1966 to 1969. Nearly every day there would be a new episode. These were these short little things, each one two minutes long or so. Starting on WCFL here in Chicago, but spreading to over 1,500 radio stations. Three times, by the way, that's three times the number in the public radio network. According to the people who syndicate Chickenman, it has been translated into German, into Dutch, into Swedish. It is still on the air, they say, in several dozen markets.
鸡侠从1966年到1969年在广播电台风靡一时。几乎每天都有新剧集。这些都是很短的东西，每一集大概两分钟左右。最初在芝加哥的WCFL电台播出，但传播到了超过1500家广播电台。顺便说一下，这个数字是公共广播网电台数量的三倍。据鸡侠的联合制作人称，它已被翻译成德语、荷兰语和瑞典语。他们说，它至今仍在几十个市场播出。
Chickenman. Chickenman existed years before National Public Radio existed as a national network. Chickenman will continue probably years after we're all gone. Like the mighty cockroach. Like-- I don't know. Like the bagel. Like [? Haleva. ?] Chickenman endures, will endure.
鸡侠。鸡侠在全国公共广播电台作为一个全国性网络成立前就已经存在多年了。鸡侠可能会在我们所有人都消失多年后继续存在。就像强大的蟑螂一样。就像——我不知道。就像百吉饼一样。就像……鸡侠长存，并将继续长存。
Well, let's hear what all the fuss was about.
那么，让我们听听大家都在争论什么。
Now another exciting episode in the life of the most fantastic crime fighter the world has ever known.
现在是世界上最神奇的犯罪斗士生活中的另一个激动人心的剧集。
Bawk, bawk, bawk, bawk!
咯咯，咯咯，咯咯！
Chickenman!
鸡侠！
He's everywhere, he's everywhere!
他无处不在，他无处不在！
Benton Harper, employed as a shoe salesman for a large downtown department store, spends his weekends, his only two days off, striking terror into the hearts of criminals everywhere as the white winged warrior called Chickenman. How did it come about that Benton Harper, weekend winged warrior, selected the visage of the chicken in his crusade against the forces of evil? Now it can be told.
本顿·哈珀，在一家大型市中心百货商店担任鞋类销售员，他利用周末仅有的两天假期，化身为名为鸡侠的白翼勇士，在各地犯罪分子的心中掀起恐惧。周末白翼勇士本顿·哈珀为何选择以鸡的形象来对抗邪恶势力？现在可以告诉你了。
[DOOR OPENING]
[开门声]
Yes, may I help you?
是的，有什么可以帮您？
How do you do? I'm looking for a costume.
你好。我想找一套服装。
What did you have in mind?
您有什么想法吗？
Something that will strike terror into the hearts of criminals everywhere.
能让各地犯罪分子的心中都感到恐惧的那种。
I see. Well, how about this?
我明白了。嗯，这件怎么样？
Hmm. No, I don't think so.
嗯。不，我不这么认为。
Why not try it on?
为什么不试一试呢？
Very well.
好吧。
Here, I'll help you.
来，我帮你。
Thank you.
谢谢。
[GRUNTING, PUTTING ON CLOTHING]
[咕哝声，穿衣服]
There you are. Now take a look in the mirror.
好了。现在照照镜子看看。
Mm. Not bad. I wonder if you would permit me to conduct a quick experiment outside this store.
嗯。还不错。不知道您是否允许我在店外做一个小实验。
Certainly.
当然可以。
[FOOTSTEPS]
[脚步声]
[DOOR OPENING]
[开门声]
Pardon me, sir.
打扰一下，先生。
Yeah?
嗯？
Are you by chance a vicious criminal?
你该不会是个穷凶极恶的罪犯吧？
Uh-huh. [AFFIRMATIVE]
嗯哼。[肯定]
Fine. Would you take a look at this costume I'm wearing?
很好。你看一下我穿的这套服装？
Yeah.
哦。
Do you feel anything strange? Anything at all?
你感觉到什么奇怪的吗？一点点也没有？
Uh, yeah.
呃，有。
And what is that?
那是什么？
I'd like to kiss ya'.
我想吻你。
Kiss me?
吻我？
Yeah.
是的。
How do you account for that?
你怎么解释这一点？
Because you look like an adorable bunny rabbit.
因为你看上去像只可爱的兔宝宝。
[KISSING SOUND]
[亲吻声]
[QUICK FOOTSTEPS]
[急促脚步声]
[DOOR OPENING]
[开门声]
Well, how did it go?
好吧，进展如何？
What else do you have?
你还有别的吗？
A teddy bear and a chicken.
泰迪熊和鸡。
A teddy bear?
泰迪熊？
Wouldn't it be cute?
那不是很可爱吗？
Wrap up the chicken, please.
请把那只鸡包起来。
Be listening tomorrow for another exciting episode in the life of the most fantastic crime fighter the world has ever known.
请收听明天世界上最神奇的犯罪斗士生活中的另一个激动人心的剧集。
Bawk, bawk, bawk, bawk!
咯咯，咯咯，咯咯！
Chickenman!
鸡侠！
He's everywhere, he's everywhere!
他无处不在，他无处不在！
I love these. You want to hear another? We have time for another. You want to hear another?
我喜欢这些。你想听另一个吗？我们还有时间听另一个。你想听另一个吗？
The thing I love is how completely low key the performances are. It's like they're not even trying. It's a complete aesthetic. All right. Let's hear one more before we continue with the next act.
我喜欢的是这些表演是多么的低调。就好像他们根本没在用力一样。这是一种完全的美学。好了，在继续下一幕之前，我们再听一个。
Now another exciting episode in the life of the most fantastic crime fighter the world has ever known.
现在是世界上最神奇的犯罪斗士生活中的另一个激动人心的剧集。
Bawk, bawk, bawk, bawk!
咯咯，咯咯，咯咯！
Chickenman!
鸡侠！
He's everywhere, he's everywhere!
他无处不在，他无处不在！
The office of the police commissioner of Midland City.
米德兰市警察局长办公室。
[PHONE RINGING]
[电话铃声]
Hello, this is the commissioner--
喂，我是局长——
Ms. Helfinger, this is the Winged Warrior.
赫尔芬格小姐，我是白翼勇士。
Yes, what is it?
是的，什么事？
Please inform the commissioner that I'm now all set for test sequence number one.
请通知局长，我已经准备好进行测试序列一了。
What?
什么？
It's all primed and ready to go.
一切准备就绪，随时可以开始。
What are you talking about?
你在说什么？
The Chicken Missile, Ms. Helfinger.
鸡导弹，赫尔芬格小姐。
The Chicken Missile?
鸡导弹？
Yes. So tell the commissioner I'm ready for test sequence number one.
是的。所以告诉局长，我已经准备好进行测试序列一了。
[INTERCOM BUZZING]
[对讲机嗡嗡声]
Yes, Ms. Helfinger?
是，赫尔芬格小姐？
Commissioner, the Chicken Missile is ready to go.
局长，鸡导弹准备好了。
Huh?
嗯？
The Chicken Missile.
鸡导弹。
Oh, yes, of course, the--
哦，是的，当然，——
And it's ready for test sequence number one.
它准备好进行测试序列一了。
Test sequence number one.
测试序列一。
Number one.
一。
Well, that's very nice. Very nice, yes.
嗯，那很好。非常好，是的。
Hello, Winger Warrior?
喂，白翼勇士？
Right right, Ms. Helfinger.
好了好了，赫尔芬格小姐。
The commissioner said that's very nice.
局长说那很好。
Oh, fine. In that case, Ms. Helfinger, have the commissioner standby with the Chicken Missile receiver.
哦，行。那样的话，赫尔芬格小姐，让局长准备好鸡导弹接收器。
What?
什么？
I'm going to countdown--
我要开始倒数了——
Listen--
听着——
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]. We'll see you at 1400 hours.
[听不清]。我们1400小时见。
Hello? Wait--
喂？等等——
[PHONE HANGING UP]
[挂断电话]
[INTERCOM BUZZING]
[对讲机嗡嗡声]
Yes, Ms. Helfinger?
是，赫尔芬格小姐？
Commissioner?
局长？
Yes.
是的。
If I would say to you, "prepare the Chicken Missile receiver," would you know--
如果我对你说“准备好鸡导弹接收器”，你会知道——
No, I wouldn't.
不，我不知道。
[WHISTLING SOUND OF MISSILE FLYING THROUGH THE AIR]
[导弹在空中飞行的呼啸声]
I didn't think you would. Commissioner?
我就知道你不知道。局长？
Yes?
是的？
I would suggest that you crouch under your desk.
我建议你蹲到桌子下面去。
Crouch under my desk?
蹲到桌子下面？
Yes, it should provide some protection.
是的，它应该能提供一些保护。
From--
防——
{WHISTLING COMES TO AN END]
[呼啸声结束]
[EXPLOSION]
[爆炸声]
[GLASS BREAKING AND RUBBLE FALLING]
[玻璃碎裂和瓦砾掉落声]
[COUGHING]
[咳嗽声]
What?
什么？
Chicken Missile.
鸡导弹。
Oh.
哦。
[SIRENS]
[警报声]
Well, say, that Chicken Missile really works nifty. Will the Midland City Fire Department recommend that a Chicken Missile receiver be installed in what's left of Midland City Hall?
嗯，说真的，那鸡导弹效果真不错。米德兰市消防局会建议在米德兰市政厅剩下的部分安装鸡导弹接收器吗？
Be listening tomorrow for another exciting episode in the life of the most fantastic crime fighter the world has ever known.
请收听明天世界上最神奇的犯罪斗士生活中的另一个激动人心的剧集。
Bawk, bawk, bawk, bawk!
咯咯，咯咯，咯咯！
Chickenman!
鸡侠！
He's everywhere, he's everywhere!
他无处不在，他无处不在！
Well, thank you very much to the creator and voice of Chickenman , Mr. Dick Orkin. Always very strange to talk to him on the phone to get permission to put these things on the radio because he sounds just like Chickenman.
非常感谢鸡侠的创作者和配音演员迪克·奥尔金先生。打电话给他请求许可将这些东西放在广播中总是很奇怪，因为他听起来就像鸡侠本人。
A collection of all the Chickenman episodes is for sale at radio-ranch.com, that's radio hyphen ranch dot com.
所有鸡侠剧集的合集在radio-ranch.com网站上有售。
Coming up, it ain't over till the fat chicken sings. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International when our program continues.
接下来，在胖鸡歌唱之前一切还没结束。稍后为您带来，来自芝加哥公共广播电台和国际公共广播电台，当节目继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme and bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's show, during this period of greatest poultry consumption in our nation-- the two weeks between Thanksgiving and Christmas-- we bring you stories of chickens, turkeys, ducks, fowl of all kind real and imagined.
这里是《这个美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，当然，我们都会选择一个主题，并为您带来各种关于该主题的故事。今天的节目，在我们国家禽肉消费量最高的时期——感恩节到圣诞节之间的两周——我们为您带来关于鸡、火鸡、鸭子、各种真实和虚构禽类的故事。
We've done this poultry show so many times year after year in November that today's show is basically a greatest hits of chicken stories from many, many years past.
我们年复一年在十一月做了这么多次家禽节目，以至于今天的节目基本上是我们多年来鸡类故事的精选集。
We've arrived at Act Three of our program. Act Three: Chicken Diva.
我们到了节目的第三幕。第三幕：鸡影后。
Chickens are what we make of them in a lot of ways. If you could possibly need further evidence of that after those first two acts we just heard, we have this story from Jack Hitt.
在很多方面，鸡是我们赋予它们意义的产物。如果你在听完刚才那前两幕后还需要进一步证明，我们有杰克·希特带来的这个故事。
Oddly enough, it wasn't Susan who was obsessed with chickens, it was Kenny, a pal who worked backstage at the 92nd Street Y in New York. His house was filled with chicken cups, chicken masks. He got the whole staff onto chickens, including Susan. For a time there in the 80s, poultry-related jokes and references became the fast way to get a laugh at the Y.
奇怪的是，痴迷于鸡的不是苏珊，而是肯尼，一个在纽约第92街Y中心后台工作的朋友。他的房子里到处都是鸡形杯子和鸡面具。他让整个员工团队都迷上了鸡，包括苏珊。在80年代的那段时间里，与家禽相关的笑话和引用成了在Y中心引起欢笑的最快方式。
I guess most of us are condemned to see nothing more than the easy comedy of chickens, but Susan Vitucci saw something else-- their potential greatness, their hidden beauty, their grandeur. One day she glued together some finger puppets for a 10 minute rendition of the Chicken Little story for her nephew. That was 14 years ago. Today it is a full length opera enjoyed by a cult following whenever it goes up in a workshop or cafe or small theater.
我想我们大多数人都被注定只能看到鸡的简单喜剧，但苏珊·维图奇看到了别的东西——它们的潜在伟大、隐藏的美丽和壮观。有一天，她把一些手指木偶粘在一起，为她的侄子演了10分钟的《鸡丁》故事。那是14年前的事了。今天，它是一部完整的歌剧，无论是在工作坊、咖啡馆还是小剧院上演，都有一群狂热的追随者。
It's still performed with finger puppets, but now it has a complete score written by a noted composer, Henry Krieger, who did Dreamgirls. The Chicken Little opera he wrote with Susan Vitucci is called Love's Fowl. Needless to say, that's F-O-W-L.
它仍然由手指木偶表演，但现在它有了一位著名作曲家亨利·克里格（他创作了《追梦女郎》）创作的完整乐谱。他与苏珊·维图奇共同创作的《鸡丁》歌剧名为《爱的家禽》（Love's Fowl），当然，是F-O-W-L（家禽）那个词。
Well, we were going to start with the opening, Siamo del Teatro Repertorio delle Mollette. We are the Clothespin Repertory Theater, and we have a special singing guest for you, which I don't know--
好吧，我们要从开场曲开始，《Siamo del Teatro Repertorio delle Mollette》。我们是衣夹木偶剧团，我们有一位特别的演唱嘉宾，我不确定——
Susan and I are sitting at Henry's baby grand piano. Henry's guest is his Maltese terrier named Toby.
苏珊和我坐在亨利的三角钢琴旁。亨利的客串嘉宾是他的马耳他梗犬托比。
Perhaps Toby would be kind enough to--
也许托比能好心地——
Yeah, would she sit on your lap for this?
是的，它能坐在你的腿上表演吗？
Yeah, no, yeah. Let's see what we can do.
是，不，是的。看看我们能做什么。
OK.
好的。
OK, listen carefully. Because once Toby gets going, he actually harmonizes with Henry and Susan.
好的，仔细听。因为一旦托比开始，它真的会和亨利与苏珊一起和声。
[MUSIC - HENRY KRIEGER AND SUSAN VITUCCI SINGING IN ITALIAN]
[音乐 - 亨利·克里格和苏珊·维图奇用意大利语演唱]
[DOG WHINING AND HOWLING TO MUSIC]
[狗随着音乐呜咽和嚎叫]
You may have noticed that this libretto is in Italian, just like a real opera.
你可能注意到这段剧本是用意大利语写的，就像真正的歌剧一样。
Before, it was just a bunch of puppets in a box, you know, with a good idea. And then suddenly, as soon as it went into Italian, it became something bigger than what it had been. And it's because when it's in English, we all kind of know it and it's really not that interesting. It's like, yeah, yeah, yeah. As soon as it's in Italian, it gives us enough distance that we can come in. You know, it makes us-- it's like the lover who doesn't want you. You don't want anybody more than you want the one who doesn't want you. Right? And so it's sort of the same thing.
以前，这只是一堆盒子里的木偶，你知道，有一个好点子。然后突然间，一旦变成意大利语，它就变得比以前更宏大了。这是因为当它是英语时，我们都熟悉它，它真的没什么意思。就像，是啊是啊是啊。一旦它用意大利语表演，它就给了我们足够的距离感，让我们能够进入它。你知道，它让我们——就像那个不想要你的情人。你最想要的莫过于那个不想要你的人。对吧？所以这是一样的道理。
[SINGING IN ITALIAN]
[用意大利语演唱]
You may recall that when you last heard of Little, back in kindergarten, she was just an average barn door fowl who had an acorn drop on her head, which she mistakenly understood to be the sky falling. Her alarms excited her friends, Goosey Loosey, Turkey Lurkey, and Ducky Lucky. And they join her for a journey to the king to tell him the important news. On the way, they meet up with Sly Fox. Little's pals eagerly accept his invitation for dinner, literally, as it turns out. Fortunately for Little, hunger is not enough to distract her from her mission, and she tracks on.
你可能记得当你最后一次听到“鸡丁”时，还在幼儿园，她只是一只普通的谷仓禽鸟，头上有个橡子掉下来，她错误地认为那是天要塌了。她的警报惊动了她的朋友，鹅精、火鸡丁和鸭丁。他们加入她，一起去找国王告诉他这个重要消息。路上，他们遇到了狡猾的狐狸。小鸡的朋友们热切地接受了他的邀请去赴宴，正如事实所证明的那样，是字面意思上的邀请。幸运的是，饥饿并不足以分散鸡丁的注意力，让她放弃使命，她继续前行。
When she meets the king, he tells her that the sky's not falling-- it's just an acorn. So the enlightened Chicken Little returns to her coop, and that's where the story ends. What are we to take away from Little's experience? I like to think it's that Little is rewarded with life, precisely because she went off on this Quixotic mission, totally in the grip of a wrong idea.
当她见到国王时，他告诉她天并没有塌——那只是个橡子。于是觉悟后的鸡丁回到了她的鸡舍，故事就在那里结束了。我们从鸡丁的经历中能得到什么启示呢？我喜欢这样想，那就是鸡丁因为进行了这次堂吉诃德式的任务，完全沉浸在一个错误的想法中，反而得到了生命的馈赠。
[SINGING IN ITALIAN]
[用意大利语演唱]
The children's fable barely figures into the story. It's just one small episode in the life of Chicken Little, now known as La Pulcina Piccola. After the acorn incident, she goes on to become an internationally renowned figure in almost every field imaginable, a diva of politics, academe, theater, art, daring-do. Like Venus, she arrives from some other world, transported on a scallop shell.
这个儿童寓言在故事中几乎没占多少比重。这只是鸡丁（现被称为La Pulcina Piccola）生活中的一个小插曲。橡子事件后，她继续成为几乎所有可想象领域的国际知名人物，政治、学术、戏剧、艺术、冒险的歌剧女主角。就像维纳斯一样，她从另一个世界而来，乘着扇贝壳运送。
But the triumphs of her life began after a youthful love affair with a fighting cock ends bitterly, and she consoles herself, as we all do at some point in our lives, by plunging into Shakespeare. She becomes an overnight sensation as an actress, celebrated all over the world for one role. Juliet? Cleopatra? Ophelia?
但她人生胜利的开始，是在与一只斗鸡的青春恋情痛苦结束后，她像我们在生命某个阶段所做的那样，通过沉浸在莎士比亚的作品中来安慰自己。她一夜成名，成为了一名女演员，因一个角色而享誉世界。朱丽叶？克利奥帕特拉？奥菲利亚？
The company then performs an excerpt of a recreation of her signature role, which is Richard III. Well, you know, I mean, Sarah Bernhardt did Hamlet.
剧团随后表演了她标志性角色《理查三世》的片段。嗯，你知道，我是说，莎拉·伯恩哈特还演过哈姆雷特呢。
Well, there's a great tradition of women playing the men's roles in Shakespeare, but I think Richard III is one of the more rare roles to be played by a woman.
嗯，女性在莎士比亚剧中扮演男性角色有着伟大的传统，但我认为《理查三世》是女性扮演的比较罕见的角色之一。
Well, that's how adventuresome an actress this chicken was.
好吧，这就是这位鸡演员有多么富有冒险精神。
I can assure you there's nothing like watching a four inch tall finger puppet crying out, "a horse, a horse-- my kingdom for a horse" in Italian. Not to mention that that puppet is a chicken, surrounded by a whole supporting cast of poultry and other avian supernumeraries. Susan says that, artistically, there's something special about chickens.
我可以向你保证，没有什么比看着一个四英寸高的手指木偶用意大利语哭喊着：“马，马——我的王国换一匹马”更令人震撼的了。更不用说那个木偶是一只鸡，周围有一群家禽和其他鸟类临时演员支持。苏珊说，在艺术上，鸡有什么特别之处。
They're a clean slate. You can put anything on them. You can project anything onto them. Because it's not like they have, to me, at least, a very strong personality.
它们是一张白纸。你可以把任何东西加在它们身上。你可以把任何东西投射到它们身上。因为在我看来，它们不像是有非常强烈个性的那种。
Except for La Pulcina. In the opera, she moves into the field of archaeology, masters it, needless to say, and makes a great discovery-- the last tomb of Gallapatra. But not before she sails the seven seas, is ship wrecked, gets rescued-- but it's by pirates-- and then she meets the pirate king.
除了“小鸡女主角”。在歌剧里，她进入了考古学领域，不用说，精通了这一行，并做出了伟大的发现——加拉帕特拉的最后陵墓。但在那之前，她航行了七大洋，遭遇了海难，被救出——但救她的是海盗——然后她遇到了海盗王。
As soon as he meets her, he falls in love with her, because of her sweet spirit. Because she comes in and she says, "here you see a little chicken who, although I'm dripping wet, I'm proud and yellow."
他一见到她就爱上了她，因为她高尚的精神。因为她走过来，她说：“在这里你看到一只小鸡，虽然我全身湿透，但我骄傲且是黄色的。”
Let me repeat that lyric for you in a purer translation. "Although I stand before you, a chicken, who is dripping wet, I am proud and I am yellow." OK. Back to Susan.
让我为你重复那句歌词的更纯粹的翻译。“虽然我站在你面前，是一只全身湿透的鸡，但我骄傲，我就是黄色的。”好的。回到苏珊的话题。
"And although I've loved and I have lost, I have learned to follow the call of adventure. So let's sail on.
“虽然我爱过又失去了，但我学会了跟随冒险的召唤。所以让我们启航吧。”
[SINGING IN ITALIAN]
[用意大利语演唱]
Keep in mind that all of the action-- like everything that occurs in every Susan Vitucci production, ever since the first one for her nephew, and continuing to this day-- occurs among characters created by sticking a small painted Styrofoam ball onto a larger painted Styrofoam ball, poking in two map tacks for eyes, gluing on a tiny felt beak, and then impaling the whole thing on top of one of those really old fashioned clothes pins that a forties cartoon figure would clamp to his nose around a chunk of Limburger cheese.
请记住，所有的动作——就像苏珊·维图奇每一部作品中发生的一切，自从为她侄子制作的第一部作品以来，直到今天——都发生在使用由一个小彩绘泡沫球粘在一个较大的彩绘泡沫球上，戳进两个地图钉作为眼睛，粘上一个微小的毛毡喙，然后把整个东西插在一根那种40年代卡通人物夹在鼻子上夹臭乳酪的非常老式的衣夹上所创造的角色之间。
[SINGING IN ITALIAN]
[用意大利语演唱]
And I could go on.
我还可以继续列举下去。
Susan has written, or she puts it, "translated" La Pulcina Piccola's diaries, which detail the other adventures that happened in between those in the opera. There are 60 pages so far, excerpts of which have appeared in Clothes Lines, the official fan club newsletter of the opera.
苏珊已经写了，或者用她的话说，“翻译”了La Pulcina Piccola的日记，详细记录了歌剧之外发生的其他冒险。目前已有60页，其中的节选出现在了歌剧官方粉丝俱乐部通讯《衣夹线》上。
Love's Fowl has a strange effect on people. I didn't understand until Susan loaned me a videotape of one performance. To be honest, I thought I would be annoyed at the intentional irony and hokiness of the puppets. But there I was with my three year old daughter, who loved the show, watching a plastic bird pantomime one of the simplest human moments, but also one of the most profound-- the confession of a great love. In this case, with a cock robin.
《爱的家禽》对人们有种奇特的影响。在苏珊借给我一份表演录像带之前我并不理解。老实说，我原以为会因为木偶的刻意讽刺和老套而感到恼火。但当我带着我三岁的女儿一起看时，她喜欢这个节目，看着一只塑料鸟模仿人类最简单的时刻，也是最深刻的时刻之一——承认伟大的爱情。在这种情况下，是与一只知更鸟。
The song that she sings as she enters goes, "I am a chicken and ready for love. My heart is as fragile as the egg from which I was born. Treat me gently, and so will I treat you. Together from earthly love, we will reach for the divine." And then she sings, "I am a chicken, and I can't fly without love. My heart, it is as strong as the egg from which I was born." And so forth.
她出场时唱的歌词是：“我是一只鸡，准备好去爱。我的心就像我出生的蛋一样脆弱。温柔地对待我，我也将那样对待你。让我们一起从世俗的爱中，去触摸神圣。”然后她唱道：“我是一只鸡，没有爱我就无法飞翔。我的心，它像我出生的蛋一样坚强。”等等。
And so it is only with Cock Robin that she flies.
所以只有和知更鸟在一起，她才能飞翔。
[SINGING IN ITALIAN]
[用意大利语演唱]
And after they've agreed to fly together, and they're soaring in the air, Cock Robin is shot and killed, murdered by a jealous sparrow. I couldn't believe it, but I was getting choked up, especially when Cock Robin appeared on the stage, his Styrofoam body spray painted black for the lament, has little magic marker eyes drawn as x's. I gathered my daughter in my arms and held on tight, as I was helplessly drawn into an expression of the grief and suffering of this little sad bird.
当他们同意一起飞翔，翱翔在空中时，知更鸟被一颗嫉妒的麻雀射杀并杀死了。我简直不敢相信，但我哽咽了，特别是当知更鸟出现在舞台上时，它那泡沫塑料做的身体被喷成了黑色以表达哀悼，还有用马克笔画的小叉作为眼睛。我把女儿搂在怀里紧紧抱住，我无助地被拉进了这种对这只悲伤的小鸟的悲痛和苦难的表达中。
In this era of slick special effects, there was something unexpectedly liberating in the marriage of this crude medium-- painted Styrofoam balls bobbing up and down behind a cardboard box-- and the high melodramatic art of Italian opera. Picture it.
在这个特效花哨的时代，这种粗糙媒介的联姻——纸箱后面上下起伏的彩绘泡沫球——与意大利歌剧高亢的情节艺术相结合，有着意想不到的解放感。想象一下。
[SINGING IN ITALIAN]
[用意大利语演唱]
I want a subscription to that newsletter.
我想订阅那个时事通讯。
Are you going to do this? I mean, are you going to be working with Pulcina Piccola, you think, for the rest of your life?
你要一直做这个吗？我是说，你觉得你会为了你的余生都致力于Pulcina Piccola的工作吗？
It's possible. And I like working with her because I get to go into a world that's inhabited by a very sweet spirit. And play with the mechanics of the world.
有可能。我喜欢和她一起工作，因为我能进入一个居住着非常甜美精神的世界。并在这个世界的机制中玩耍。
And because it's very small-- I could never have afforded to produce this show with people. But I could afford to do it with clothespins. So I can do as big a production as I want with clothespins. I can have stuff fly in and out and come in from traps, and I can have all kinds of fancy, flashy stuff that costs millions of dollars to do on Broadway. And it costs me $200 because I had to buy lots and lots of Styrofoam and clothespins and stuff, and all this, and a new table maybe. And I get to do whatever I want.
而且因为它是非常小的——我永远负担不起用真人制作这个节目。但我负担得起用衣夹来做。所以我可以随心所欲地制作像百老汇那样大的制作。我可以让东西飞进飞出，从活板门进来，我可以有各种各样花哨的、闪耀的东西，在百老汇做这些要花几百万美元。而对我来说只花200美元，因为我得买大量的泡沫塑料、衣夹之类的东西，还有一张新桌子也许。我可以随心所欲做任何我想做的事。
[SINGING IN ITALIAN]
[用意大利语演唱]
Jack Hitt is a writer who lives in New Haven.
杰克·希特是一位居住在纽黑文的作家。
[MUSIC - "FINGER LICKIN' GOOD" BY THE BEASTIE BOYS]
[音乐 - 野兽男孩的《手指舔得好》]
Act Four-- Trying To Respect The Chicken.
第四幕——试图尊重鸡。
Sure, it's one thing to take a fictional character like Chicken Little and make her into a star. Try doing that with a real chicken. Just try.
当然，拿“鸡丁”这样的虚构角色并让她成为明星是一回事。尝试用一只真正的鸡来做这件事。试试看。
Well, these are photographs of chickens. The first one here is a Silver Laced Wyandotte. It's a black and white bird, essentially, but the tail feathers have a lot of iridescent green coloring.
嗯，这些是鸡的照片。第一张是一只银纹怀恩多特鸡。这基本上是一只黑白相间的鸟，但尾羽有很多绚丽的绿色色彩。
In a world where chickens get no respect, Tamara Staples treats them the way the humans treat those we revere most. She takes their portraits lovingly. Her shots are like fashion photographs, beautifully-lit, color backdrops. They're beautiful.
在这个鸡得不到尊重的世界里，塔玛拉·斯台普斯用我们崇敬人类的方式对待它们。她充满爱意地拍摄它们的肖像。她的拍摄就像时装摄影，有精美的照明、彩色背景。它们很漂亮。
The first one looked regal, but now you've just turned to one where it almost looks like-- it's like a clown. it looks comic.
第一张看起来很威严，但你刚才转到了一张几乎看起来像——就像个小丑。看起来很滑稽。
Mm-hm. [AFFIRMATIVE] It's a modeled Houdan, which I always sort of call the Phyllis Diller chicken, which is--
嗯。[肯定] 这是一个斑点乌丹鸡，我总是把它称为菲利斯·狄勒（喜剧演员）鸡，也就是——
Oh, my God. That chicken does look like Phyllis Diller.
哦，天哪。那只鸡看起来真的像菲利斯·狄勒。
It does. It's the hat. It looks like it's got this huge feathered hat sort of thing, and a strange body shape.
确实。就是那顶帽子。它看起来好像戴着一顶巨大的羽毛帽子之类东西，还有奇怪的身形。
In a way, it's like Tamara Staples is running an odd little cross-species science experiment, one that asks this question: what happens when you try to treat a chicken the way we treat humans? Even if it's just for the length of a photo shoot.
某种程度上，塔玛拉·斯台普斯就像是在进行一个奇怪的跨物种科学实验，一个提出了这样一个问题：当你试图以对待人类的方式对待鸡时会发生什么？即使只是在拍摄的一段时间里。
What happens, it turns out, is that you learn just where the thin line is that divides human beings from birds. All right. Maybe it's not such a thin line, but it's definitely a line, and, like most city people, I had never thought about it. About where it lays, about what it might be, what it might consist of, until Tamara and I headed out to a farm.
结果证明发生的事情是，你了解了区分人类和鸟类的界限有多薄。好了。也许这不是那么薄的界限，但它绝对是一个界限，像大多数城市人一样，我从来没想过它。关于它在哪，它可能是什么，它可能由什么组成，直到塔玛拉和我出发前往一个农场。
[ROOSTER CROWING]
[公鸡打鸣声]
[CHICKENS CLUCKING]
[鸡咯咯声]
I think that is the best one.
我想那只是最好的一只。
Yeah, we've got to get him. We don't want him to get dirty or anything, do we? Or does it matter?
是的，我们必须抓住它。我们不想让它变脏什么的，对吧？或者没关系？
She runs loose every day.
她每天都在外面散步。
Can you find her?
你能找到她吗？
Yeah, we can take her out.
是的，我们可以把她带出来。
We're going to get him to-- we're going to have to wrangle them, you know.
我们要抓住它们，你知道。
We're at the Davidson's Dairy Farm, about an hour and a half northwest of Chicago. Family members present-- Paul, who's helping Tamara choose a bird to photograph, his sister Laura, who's studying photography at a nearby university, the grandfather, George Cairns, a veteran breeder, their father, Dick, who seems the most skeptical of this whole project, but who patiently shows Tamara and her assistant, Dennis, the milking barn as a possible place to set up and shoot.
我们在戴维森奶牛场，距离芝加哥西北部约一个半小时路程。在场的家庭成员——保罗，他正在帮塔玛拉挑选拍摄的鸟，他的妹妹劳拉，她在附近的一所大学学习摄影，爷爷乔治·凯恩斯，一位资深饲养员，他们的父亲迪克，他看起来对整个项目最怀疑，但他耐心地带塔玛拉和她的助手丹尼斯去挤奶棚作为设置和拍摄的可能场所。
What kind of an area are you looking for?
你们在寻找什么样的区域？
Well, maybe-- it could be a little wider, don't you think? And if it could be from here to there, and know that pole to that pole.
嗯，也许——它可能再宽一点，你不觉得吗？如果是从这里到那里，知道那根杆子到那根杆子。
For what?
为了什么？
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
[说话声重叠]
Well, we are set-- maybe this is a good time to pull out the portfolio.
嗯，我们设置好了——也许现在是拿出作品集的好时机。
OK.
好的。
You want to grab it?
你想抓起它吗？
I'm actually-- it's a study of the birds. But it's an isolated study, so it doesn't-- people aren't necessarily associating it with the farm and something to eat.
我实际上是——这是一个关于鸟类的研究。但这是一个孤立的研究，所以它不——人们不一定把它与农场和可以吃的东西联系起来。
Tamara takes us all outside the barn-- so dust won't get on her photos-- and shows them her shots, name dropping the names of some big chicken people, people whose birds she's photographed. Including Bob Wulff, editor of The Poultry Press. Dick notices that a bird in one photo has crooked toes.
塔玛拉带我们所有人走出谷仓——这样灰尘就不会弄到她的照片上——并向他们展示了她的拍摄作品，还顺便提到了她拍摄过的一些“大鸡人物”，比如《家禽新闻》的编辑鲍勃·沃尔夫。迪克注意到一张照片里的一只鸟有弯曲的脚趾。
Probably on a hard surface you turn--
可能是在坚硬的表面上你转——
What do you guys think of the pictures?
你们觉得这些照片怎么样？
Well, the pictures are nice and sharp. I mean, there's nothing wrong with the pictures. If there's anything to find fault with, it's the birds. You know, they aren't posing the way they should, some of them.
嗯，这些照片很漂亮，很清晰。我是说，照片本身没什么问题。如果有什么可以挑剔的，那就是那些鸟。你知道，它们没有按照它们应该的方式摆姿势，有些是这样。
Fact is, while city people usually go nuts when they see Tamara's pictures, a lot of chicken breeders don't like them. And to understand why, to fully comprehend this little culture clash here in America, we have to leave the barnyard for a minute and flash back to something that happened back at Tamara's apartment in the city.
事实上，虽然城市人在看到塔玛拉的照片时通常会发疯，但许多养鸡人不喜欢它们。要理解原因，要完全理解这里在美国发生的这种小文化冲突，我们必须离开谷仓一分钟，回闪到塔玛拉在城市公寓里发生的事情。
Tamara showed me this old red book from the turn of the century. This is a book the seal of the American Poultry Association in gold on the front. And then, right there in gold letters--
塔玛拉给我看了这本世纪之交的老红书。这是一本封面上有美国家禽协会金印的书。然后，就在那儿，用金色的字母写着——
Standard of Perfection. The Standard of Perfection is really the bible of poultry standards. You know, what birds are--
《完美标准》。《完美标准》确实是家禽标准的圣经。你知道，鸟是什么——
Tamara flipped past the engravings and illustrations of chickens of all types and breeds. These were show chickens, standing the way that chickens stand in competitions. Then Tamara pulled out one of her own photos to compare, to show me how her poses do not meet the standard in the book.
塔玛拉翻过了各种类型和品种的鸡的雕刻和插图。这些是展示鸡，按照鸡在比赛中站立的方式站立。然后塔玛拉拿出她自己的一张照片进行比较，向我展示她的摆姿势是如何不符合书中的标准。
The tail needs to be higher. Her feet are not erect, standing. Chest isn't out. Head, it needs to be up more. And it shows-- I mean, you can see the shape of the chicken much better in the Standard of Perfection pose.
尾巴需要更高。她的脚不是挺直地站着。胸部没有挺出来。头，需要再抬高一些。它显示——我是说，在《完美标准》的姿势中，你可以看得更清楚鸡的形状。
See, to me, what's so interesting, though, is that the Standard of Perfection doesn't include a personality.
看，对我来说，最有趣的是《完美标准》不包括个性。
Right. Because it's not about personality. It's about breeding.
对。因为它不是关于个性的。它是关于繁育的。
And so is that a pose that the owners would want to own a photo of?
那么这是一种主人想要拥有照片的姿势吗？
They are very particular about this-- they want to see their bird in the Standard of Perfection pose. Definitely. Because that's what they've been taught from 4-H, when they were kids, to do.
他们对这个非常讲究——他们想看到他们的鸟以《完美标准》的姿势展示。绝对的。因为那是他们从小在4-H俱乐部里被教导要做的。
That's for them. For herself, for her city customers, she uses the others. OK, back to the barnyard.
那是给他们看的。对她自己，对她的城市顾客，她用的是其他的。好了，回到谷仓。
[CHICKEN SQUAKING]
[鸡尖叫声]
Tamara and the Davidsons decide to set up the photo session in a room that's usually used to store feed for the cows. It takes about 45 minutes to set this up. That 45 minutes includes dismantling and moving a wall of hay that is probably 10 feet high and 15 feet long. This takes five people.
塔玛拉和戴维森一家决定在一个通常用来储存牛饲料的房间里设置拍摄环节。设置这个花了大约45分钟。那45分钟包括拆除和移动一面可能是10英尺高、15英尺长的干草墙。这花了五个人。
Then in comes the power and the fancy lights and the cloth backdrop that gets hung from the steel pole. The backdrop is ironed first with an iron and ironing board brought from the city just for that purpose.
然后是电力和花哨的灯光，以及挂在钢管上的布背景。背景首先用从城市专门带来的熨斗和熨衣板熨平。
11 and 1/2, 11, and an 8 and 1/2?
11.5，11，还有一个8.5？
Yeah. 11 and 1/2-- your test is going to be at 11 and 1/2, 11, and 8 and 1/2. We're going to shoot your film at 11.
是的。11.5——你的测试将在11.5、11和8.5。我们要用11的光圈拍你的胶片。
It was cold. Well below freezing. So cold that the Polaroid film that Tamara uses for lighting tests would not fully develop.
天很冷。远低于冰点。冷到塔玛拉用来测试灯光的宝丽来胶片无法完全显影。
You ready for the bird?
准备好那只鸟了吗？
We're close. Just want to commune with the bird.
快了。只想和那只鸟交流一下。
We just want to make you pretty. Look how sweet, aren't you? You know what, I'm going to photograph you. My name is Tamara, I'll be your photographer for today.
我们只想让你变漂亮。看多甜美，你不是吗？你知道吗，我要拍你。我叫塔玛拉，我将是你今天的摄影师。
Our first bird is a white Cornish, a show bird who belongs to George. His show bird is used to being picked up and handled. Part of preparing chickens for shows involves handling them a lot so they'll be calm with the judges.
我们的第一只鸟是一只白科尼什鸡，一只属于乔治的展示鸟。他的展示鸟习惯了被捡起和处理。为展示准备鸡的一部分工作涉及大量的处理，这样它们在评委面前才会冷静。
If you could just nudge his head up a little bit, he's perfect. He's got his chest out. Now he's got his face in-- OK. Yeah, you know what we want. Yeah, you're-- great, George. He's got a feather on his back here.
如果你能稍微把它的头抬起来一点，它就很完美了。它的胸部挺出来了。现在它的脸进去了——好的。是的，你知道我们想要什么。是的，你——太棒了，乔治。它的背上有根羽毛。
Tamara has the Cornish stand up on a stack of little red antique books-- kind of unsteady.
塔玛拉让科尼什鸡站在一堆小红色古董书上——有点摇晃。
Things go well for a while. She gets a half dozen good shots of the bird. Expressive shots. More personality than Standard of Perfection, George tells me. The bird's chest isn't high enough, it's body is not turned correctly to the camera. And then the bird stops cooperating. He gets tired. Paul has a suggestion.
事情顺利了一会儿。她拍了半打那只鸟的好照片。富有表现力的照片。乔治告诉我，比《完美标准》有更多的个性。这只鸟的胸部不够高，它的身体没有正确地转向相机。然后那只鸟停止了合作。它累了。保罗有一个建议。
Bring in a pull-it.
带来一只母鸡。
You know what? You know that works.
你知道吗？那管用。
Maybe we should explain what that is. What does that mean to bring a pull-it?
也许我们应该解释一下那是什么。带来一只母鸡意味着什么？
Thinks maybe a female will perk him up.
觉得也许雌性会使它振作起来。
Laura grabs a hen and waves it at the flaccid cock. The cock does not rise. I can say that on the radio, right?
劳拉抓住一只母鸡，对着那只没精打采的公鸡挥舞。公鸡没有站起来。我在广播里可以这么说吧？
Well, it probably would have been better to get the one from the other pen that he's not used to.
嗯，可能最好是从它不熟悉的另一个鸡舍里抓一只。
Fresh blood. Bring him around a little bit so his back--
新鲜血液。带它转一转，让它的背——
For real? The chicken-- the rooster will show off more for a hen that it doesn't know?
真的吗？鸡——公鸡会在它不认识的母鸡面前展示更多吗？
Yes. If you put a new hen in with him, or him in with a group a new hens, he will really show off.
是的。如果你把一只新母鸡放进它那里，或者把它放进一群新母鸡中，它会真的展示一番。
They try this and that, nothing with much success. Finally, with one shot left, Paul suggests putting a hen into the picture with the rooster.
他们试了这个和那个，没什么太大的成功。最后，剩下最后一张照片时，保罗建议在照片中放一只母鸡和公鸡。
Get the girl to-- she looks like her feet are so far apart, she's really struggling to stand.
让那个女孩——她看起来脚分得那么开，她在努力地站着。
That's the way they stand, though.
那是它们站立的方式。
[INAUDIBLE PHRASE].
[听不清]。
That's all right, that's all right. Ah-- [CAMERA CLICKS] Oh, did you see that?
没关系，没关系。啊——[相机快门声] 哦，你看到了吗？
Yeah.
是的。
All right, we got it.
好的，我们拍到了。
Why? What did she just do? Describe--
为什么？她刚才做了什么？描述一下——
She looked up at him very sweetly. Like that. With her head cocked. The male bird was posing, and she was posing also, but had a personality of just being like the sweet, doting mother, you now?
她很甜美地看着它。就像那样。歪着头。那只公鸟在摆姿势，她也在摆姿势，但有一种就像甜美、慈爱的母亲那样的个性，你懂吗？
But not Standard of Perfection.
但不符合《完美标准》。
So we're done with this background, and--
所以我们这个背景拍完了，然后——
Not Standard of Perfection. Even these perfectly bred Cornishes could not achieve the Standard of Perfection today. And even in this goofy, un-bird-like situation, an hour of watching them makes clear just how hard it is to ever get birds to hit the standard. Which is to say not only do we completely dominate every aspect of the lives of chickens-- their births, their feed, their eggs, their slaughter-- not only have we bred them to human specifications to meet human needs, but we have created a standard for what it means to be a chicken that most chickens can never meet. That's what the standard means. We judge them as chickens, and we find them lacking. If they had brains to understand this, they would be right to feel indignant.
不符合《完美标准》。即使是这些完美培育的科尼什鸡今天也无法达到《完美标准》。即使在这种笨拙的、不像鸟的情况中，一个小时观察它们让人们清楚地看到让鸟类达到标准有多困难。也就是说，我们不仅完全主导了鸡生活的方方面面——它们的出生、饲料、鸡蛋、屠宰——我们不仅为了满足人类的需求而按人类规范培育它们，而且我们创造了一个关于鸡意味着什么的“标准”，大多数鸡永远无法达到。这就是标准的意思。我们评价它们是鸡，却发现它们不合格。如果它们有大脑能理解这一点，它们是有理由感到愤怒的。
But of course, this is a city person's perspective, and that means it is completely wrong-headed from the point of view of anybody who actually raises birds. Standing in the cold feed room, I had a long, long talk with George about this. George is 80 years old. He's been raising birds since the-- I guess the Calvin Coolidge administration. And he says the whole fun of raising birds is raising them to the standard.
但当然，这是城市人的视角，这意味着从任何真正养鸟的人的角度来看，这是完全错误的。站在寒冷的饲料室里，我就此和乔治进行了长时间的交谈。乔治80岁了。他自——我想是卡尔文·柯立芝政府时期就开始养鸟了。他说养鸟的全部乐趣在于把它们养成标准。
Well, like, for instance, if your birds lack bone, OK, you go out and buy a bird as near to like them as you can with better bone. But when you mate them together, you might get long-legged birds, or too short. I mean, you don't get what you want just by mating. It takes four or five years to gradually get it out, and by that time, they're inbred and you need new ones.
嗯，比如，如果你的鸟缺乏骨骼，好吧，你就去买一只尽可能像它们但骨骼更好的鸟。但当你把它们配对在一起时，你可能会得到长腿的鸟，或者太短的。我是说，你不能仅仅通过配对得到你想要的。这需要四五年时间慢慢把它弄出来，到那时，它们已经近亲繁殖，你需要新的。
George tells me that when he's breeding a new batch of birds, he'll hatch 65 of them, and only one or two will be anywhere near the Standard of Perfection. That's how hard it is.
乔治告诉我，当他繁育一批新鸟时，他会孵化65只，只有一两只会接近《完美标准》。这就是它有多难。
Do you get frustrated with the Standard Of Protection sometimes?
你有时会对《保护标准》感到沮丧吗？
No, we get frustrated with the judges. Because every judge has his own idea of what the standard should be.
不，我们对评委感到沮丧。因为每个评委都有自己关于标准应该是什么样的想法。
I thought that's the whole point of a standard, is that--
我以为这就是标准的全部意义所在，那就是——
That is. But one judge will want it this way, and another another. Today, if you bred your birds to the standard of perfection-- weight and everything-- and took them to the show, you probably wouldn't get anywhere. You've got to breed to the fads.
确实。但一个评委想要这样，另一个想要那样。今天，如果你按照完美标准——重量等等——繁育你的鸟，并把它们带去展示，你可能什么也得不到。你必须按潮流繁育。
That's right. The fads. Like Cornishes these days are supposed to have shorter legs than the real Standard of Perfection. Vertical tail feathers are out in all sorts of breeds that really should have them. In the country, among the chicken breeders, they think about a lot of things you never get to in the city.
没错。潮流。比如科尼什鸡这些日子应该比真正的《完美标准》腿更短。垂直的尾羽在很多本该有的品种中已经过时了。在乡村，在养鸡人中间，他们考虑了很多你在城市里永远不会触及的事情。
And when you're raising these birds, with any of these birds, do you have a close relationship with a bird the way some do [UNINTELLIGIBLE] with a pet?
当你养这些鸟时，对于这些鸟中的任何一只，你有像有些人对待宠物那样和某只鸟有亲密关系吗？
I don't have time. Yeah, I got too many things to do. See, a few years ago, I almost died of cancer, and the Good Lord told me how to cure myself. And so I've been working with that a lot the last three years. I've been helping people, and put in papers. Now it's getting all over the United States.
我没时间。是的，我有太多事要做了。看，几年前，我差点死于癌症，上帝告诉我如何治愈自己。所以我过去三年一直在那方面做很多工作。我一直在帮助人们，并提交论文。现在它正在遍布美国。
What did you do? What do you do?
你做了什么？你做什么？
It's you use the root of a dandelion. Simple as can be. But there's something in that that builds up your blood and your immune system.
它是使用蒲公英的根。简单得不能再简单了。但其中有什么东西能增强你的血液和免疫系统。
Wait a second. You're saying that you were diagnosed with cancer, and this is the only treatment you've had, and it cured you?
等一下。你是说你被诊断出患有癌症，而这是你接受过的唯一治疗，它治愈了你？
Yeah. And I've given it to other people when the medical world has told them that there's nothing more they can do, and they've gotten well, too. But not all of them. If they're too far gone, it won't help them.
是的。当医疗界告诉他们已经无能为力时，我也给了别人，他们也好了。但并不是所有的人。如果他们病得太重，它帮不了他们。
And you make it into tea or something like that?
你把它做成茶之类的东西吗？
We just put it in a little water, a little milk, Kool-Aide. You can put it on a sandwich. Anything that isn't hot.
我们只是把它放在一点水、一点牛奶、酷艾乐饮料里。你可以把它放在三明治上。任何不热的东西。
George gives me a pamphlet that he's written up. No doctor has actually checked him out to prove the cancer is gone from his body. He's actually got no hard scientific proof that this really works, but he says God told him that this is the way he should be spending his time. And it has cut into his bird breeding a bit.
乔治给了我一本他写的小册子。没有医生真正检查过他以证明他体内的癌症已经消失。他实际上没有任何确凿的科学证据证明这真的有效，但他说上帝告诉他这是他应该花时间做的方式。它确实让他养鸟的工作减少了一些。
George leaves, off on other business. Tamara is finished hanging and lighting the next backdrop. And the rest of us begin with the second bird, a bird called a Brahma, with elaborately patterned brown and white feathers.
乔治离开了，去处理其他事务。塔玛拉完成了挂起和照明下一个背景。我们其余的人开始处理第二只鸟，一种叫婆罗门鸡的鸟，有着精心装饰的棕色和白色羽毛。
[BIRD CLUCKING]
[鸟的咯咯声]
Got her.
抓到她了。
She is big. This is a chicken like the size of a dog.
她很大。这是一只像狗那么大的鸡。
Not that big.
没那么大。
A small dog.
一只小狗。
[LAUGHING]
[笑]
Our second bird demonstrates the great distance between bird, instinct, and intelligence. And the demands of modern fashion photography, which is to say, of civilization. Called upon to do human tasks, even rather passive ones, a bird remains a bird.
我们的第二只鸟展示了鸟类、本能和智慧之间的巨大鸿沟。以及现代时尚摄影的需求，也就是说，现代文明的需求。被要求做人类的任务，甚至是相当被动的任务，鸟终究还是鸟。
Paul carries the huge hen onto the fragile little set Tamara has built.
保罗把那只巨大的母鸡扛到塔玛拉建造的脆弱小布景上。
He's a beauty. What ya eating there, buddy?
她是位美女。你在吃什么，伙计？
[BIRD SQUAKING]
[鸟的尖叫声]
Whew, it slapped me.
呼，它拍了我一下。
"I'm scared of this one," she says, quietly, as she adjusts her camera. The chicken is so big-- nine pounds, the size of a small consumer turkey-- that she has to pull the camera back. the Davidsons are looking at her skeptically. Paul asked pointedly if she's ever shot a bird this big.
“我害怕这个，”她轻声说道，同时调整相机。这只鸡太大了——九磅重，一只小型的消费火鸡那么大——她不得不把相机往后拉。戴维森一家怀疑地看着她。保罗直截了当地问她是否拍过这么大的鸟。
We've got to figure out where the--
我们得弄清楚哪——
[BIRD SQUACKING]
[鸟的尖叫声]
Whoa.
哇。
[BIRD CLUCKING]
[鸟的咯咯声]
Hello, bird. Are you going to slap me in the face again? I hope not.
你好，鸟儿。你还要再拍我的脸吗？我希望不要。
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] jump right in your face.
[听不清] 直接跳到你的脸上。
You know why you're here? Let's talk. We need you to be beautiful. Here's your moment. OK? There are more where you came from, buddy. You better act up here.
你知道你为什么在这儿吗？我们谈谈。我们需要你变得漂亮。这是你的时刻。好吗？你来的地方还有很多，伙计。你最好在这儿表现好点。
This combination of coddling and threats might motivate an aspiring supermodel, or an eager puppy. But this, after all, is a chicken. Laura tries to lure it up with a handful of corn.
这种溺爱和威胁的结合可能会激励一个有抱负的超级名模，或者一只急切的小狗。但这终究是一只鸡。劳拉试着用一把玉米把它诱引上来。
She standing--
她站着——
She can get corn, or she's trying to get it, but she has to stand up high for it.
她能得到玉米，或者她试图得到它，但她必须站得很高才能得到。
Is that where you want her to stand?
那是你想让她站的地方吗？
Someone during this ordeal, a funny thing happens. All the Davidsons, who all started off skeptical, they are completely engaged. Dick suggests a pose that is pure art concept, a pose that could not be further from Standard of Perfection. Laura lures the bird with corn, Paul smooths feathers, and when the bird quivers or moves a wing, three people jump in to fix it back up.
在这个折磨人的过程中，发生了一件有趣的事。所有一开始持怀疑态度的戴维森一家，他们完全投入了。迪克建议了一个纯艺术概念的姿势，一个离《完美标准》最远的姿势。劳拉用玉米诱引这只鸟，保罗梳理羽毛，当鸟颤抖或移动翅膀时，三个人冲进去把它修好。
There's some feathers on the breast a little bit. A little bit fluffy. You know, it's like she's not real cleaned on there-- OK. She's a little farther. You guys are a great team. I'm going to hire you to come with me.
胸部有一些羽毛。有一点蓬松。你知道，就像她没在那儿清理干净一样——好的。她再远一点。你们是一个很棒的团队。我要雇你们和我一起去。
Oops, I got a hand in there.
噢，我把手拍进去了。
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
[说话声重叠]
[LAUGHING]
[笑]
Move the hand, move the hand. Move the hand. OK, great.
移开手，移开手。移开手。好的，太棒了。
It wasn't until this point that I realized that I came into this sort of expecting the bird to be more, well, more human. Partly, I think, because I had never really thought about this one way or the other. But partly because Tamara's photos make chicken seem so thoughtful.
直到这一点我才意识到，我来这里本来有点期待这只鸟能更……嗯，更人性化。一部分是因为我从来没想过这件事。但部分是因为塔玛拉的照片让鸡看起来很深思熟虑。
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
[听不清]。
[PEOPLE CLICKING TO GET BIRD'S ATTENTION]
[人们打响指以引起鸟的注意]
Over here. Look at the camera, look at the camera. Right there.
这边。看相机，看相机。就在那儿。
No, she's completely out of frame.
不，她完全在画面外。
Those photos are a lie.
那些照片是个谎言。
[PEOPLE CLICKING TO GET BIRD'S ATTENTION]
[人们打响指以引起鸟的注意]
Hello?
喂？
I think you're going to have a one shot opportunity here. It's going to be when I let go.
我想你在这儿有一个机会，只有一次机会。那将是我放手的时候。
[CHICKEN CLUCKING]
[鸡的咯咯声]
[WINGS FLUTTERING]
[翅膀拍打声]
Whoa. Geez, I didn't even let go. I just started to let up and he yanked it right out of my hand.
哇。天哪，我甚至还没放手。我只是开始松手，它就把它从我手里拽出去了。
Fact is, you can try to give chickens respect. You can try to treat them dignity, and photograph them the way you'd photograph anything or anyone that's serious, but the chickens will not care. You can make them look dignified, but it is a brainless, bird-like dignity, and it is ephemeral.
事实是，你可以尝试给鸡尊重。你可以尝试对待它们有尊严，并像拍摄任何严肃的人或物一样拍摄它们，但鸡并不在乎。你可以让它们看起来有尊严，但那是一种无脑的、鸟一样的尊严，而且是短暂的。
Do you feel like your relationship with chicken has changed because of this?
你觉得你和鸡的关系因为这个改变了吗？
No. Not at all.
不。完全没有。
How could that not be so?
怎么会这样呢？
Um, I order the chicken when I'm at the show. I eat it right in front of the chickens.
嗯，我在展示的时候点鸡肉吃。我就在鸡面前吃它。
You eat chicken while you're standing there with a chicken?
你站在那儿和一只鸡在一起时吃鸡肉？
Yes. [LAUGHING] Is it wrong? I don't know. I'm hungry.
是的。[笑] 这错了吗？我不知道。我饿了。
Well, no wonder they won't sit still.
好吧，难怪它们坐不住。
Yeah.
是的。
[CHICKING CALLING]
[鸡的呼叫声]
We pack up our gear and move the massive wall of hay back into place. As we do this, chickens hop by. Brahmas, Americanas, mixed breeds. They seem utterly uninterested in us. They cluck at each other, there's feed to eat, hay to nestle in-- they have better things to do with their time. And you know, there's nothing that makes you realize just how inhuman chickens are than spending a day trying to make them seem human.
我们收拾好装备，把那堵巨大的干草墙移回原处。当我们做这件事时，鸡跳了过来。婆罗门鸡、美国鸡、杂交鸡。它们对我们完全没兴趣。它们互相咯咯叫，有饲料吃，有干草可以筑巢——它们有更重要的事情要做。你知道，没有什么比花一整天试图让鸡看起来像人更能让你意识到鸡是多么不像人了。
[CHICKEN AND COW SOUNDS]
[鸡和牛的声音]
Well, the stories in today's program were produced by Alex Blumberg, Susan Burton, Blue Chevigny, Julie Snyder, Alix Spiegel and Nancy Updike. Musical help from Mr. John Connors. Thanks also to Larry Josephson and Jay Hedblade. Elizabeth Meister runs our web site.
嗯，今天节目中的故事由亚历克斯·布卢姆伯格、苏珊·伯顿、蓝色·切维尼、朱莉·斯奈德、阿利克斯·斯皮格尔和南希·厄普代克制作。来自约翰·康纳斯先生的音乐帮助。也感谢拉里·约瑟夫森和杰伊·赫德布莱德。伊丽莎白·迈斯特负责我们的网站。
Tamara Staples' photographs of chickens are now in a book called Fairest Fowl: Portraits of Championship Chickens. Susan Vitucci's opera about Chicken Little is available on CD at www.pulcina.org. That is Pulcina spelled, of course, P-U-L-C-I-N-A.
塔玛拉·斯台普斯的鸡的照片现在被收录在一本名为《最美的家禽：冠军鸡的肖像》的书里。苏珊·维图奇关于鸡丁的歌剧可以在www.pulcina.org网站上以CD形式购买。当然，“Pulcina”的拼写是P-U-L-C-I-N-A。
WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia, who decided he did not want to come onto our program after he asked just one question--
WBEZ的管理监督由托里·马拉蒂亚负责，他决定在问了一个问题后不想参加我们的节目——
This is just radio, not TV?
这只是广播，不是电视？
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周再见，会有更多《这个美国生活》的故事。
PRI. Public Radio International.
PRI。国际公共广播电台。